on se laisse aujourd'hui les premiers
rollers électriques au monde c'est une
boîte française qui fait ça s'appelle
Atmos gear j'y vais j'ai ma petite
Téléco je prends un peu de vitesse je me
penche à l'avant et j'accélère et je
suis parti donc avec le système est
hyper malin j'ai tout qui est connecté
dans une petite banane dans lequel je
vais avoir ma batterie genre mon moteur
et là j'ai ma Téléco qui est connecté
bien évidemment en Bluetooth donc ce
qu'on me conseille de faire c'est de
commencer à patiner pour partir histoire
d'avoir des gens un peu de mouvement et
de pas me casser la gueule parce que si
vous l'ouvrez à fond vous partez vous
vous rassâtinez comme une grosse merde
et il y a un autre truc qui est
vachement bien c'est quoi ce que je
patine tout seul comme ça vous voyez
sans utiliser ma batterie sans utiliser
l'énergie et bien je vais récupérer de
l'énergie un peu comme sur une voiture
électrique parce que ça fait un effet de
dynamo donc ça fait remonter le courant
directement donc vous voyez dans tous
les cas je peux en faire et ce qui est
cool c'est que lorsque je me débranche
je peux continuer à les utiliser comme
n'importe quel paire de roller c'est un
produit vous pouvez commander tout de
suite sur le site Atmos gear.com pour
des livraisons à partir du mois de mai
donc dépêchez-vous on peut retrouver en
électrique des trottinettes on peut
retrouver en électrique et bien à
skateboard mais on retrouve pas jusqu'à
présent en électrique des rollers comme
ça c'est quasiment chose faite ça va
arriver Atmos gear dites-moi ça pourrait
vous intéresser surtout de marquer le
moi en bas dans les commentaires